[Musique]
très tôt j'ai fait l'expérience de trois
choses la première que les mots peuvent
faire mal très mal et qui peuvent
laisser des traces
très longtemps la deuxième
quinze enfants qui n'est pas écoutée
dans ce qu'il vit dans ce qu'il ressent
perd confiance en lui et que même s'il
peut paraître en situation de réussite
vu de l'extérieur il peut être en grande
souffrance
à l'intérieur la troisième qui peut y
avoir un décalage très important entre
les belles intentions de l'adulte et la
réalité de ce que l'enfant vit et
l'impact que cela a sur lui car s'il ya
bien une chose que je voyais c'était les
belles intentions de l'adulte et encore
maintenant je dis je n'ai jamais vu un
adulte qui est des mauvaises intentions
pour les enfants dont il s'occupe
ils veulent tous qu'ils soient heureux
et épanoui mais dans la réalité
combien d'enfants le sont vraiment et
combien d'adultes de parents
d'enseignants sont heureux de la qualité
de relation qu'il vive avec les enfants
comme premier métier j'ai choisi d'être
professeur d'éducation physique
déjà à l'époque j'ai essayé d'inventer
une forme d'autorité qui ne soit pas
l'autorité pouvoir de l'adulte que
j'avais vécu une autorité qui a la foi
donne du cadre et en même temps qui
permet d'être en lien avec l'être humain
quels élèves de prendre en compte
je tâtonnais par moi-même pour essayer
de vivre mes convictions
et puis dans mon cheminement personnel
et professionnel
j'ai découvert la communication non
violente de marshall rosenberg qui m'a
donné quelques clés essentielles pour
pouvoir vivre
la qualité de relation à laquelle
j'aspirais et j'ai le plaisir de vous
partager quelques-unes de ses clés alors
l'axé central c'est le fait d'être à
l'écouté de nos sensations et de nos
émotions à la fois les nôtres est aussi
celle des autres pourquoi parce que ce
sont les indicateurs précieux de comment
va la vie en nous tout comme des fleurs
nous avons des besoins qui sont liées à
la vie si nos besoins sont bien pris en
compte
alors nous sommes épanouie et si nos
besoins ne sont pas très bien pris en
compte
alors il ya quelque chose qui fans en
nous et ça va être là une des premières
clés pour une éducation bienveillante
l'accueil des émotions de l'enfant si un
enfant cours tombe et se relève en
pleurant cessons de lui dire a laissé
rien et cherchons plutôt à accueillir ce
qu'il vit tu as eu peur tu as mal est un
pas plus loin
apprenons aussi à nous relier à ce qui
est important pour l'enfant
derrière son émotion si je vais au parc
avec mon enfant qui joue au toboggan
puis à un moment je lui dis allez c'est
l'heure on rentre et que là il me dit tu
es méchante maman au lieu de lui dire
attention tu ne bat pas comme ça sinon
tu vas voir une fessée et bien je peux
entendre qui vit et lui proposer est ce
que tu es furieux parce que tu voulais
encore joué toboggan savez vous combien
fait important d'accueillir comme cela
les émotions les neurosciences nous
montre maintenant que jusqu'à l'âge de 6
ans le cerveau de l'enfant n'est pas
complètement développé et qu'en
particulier les zones du cerveau qui
permettent d' or de contrôler les
émotions ne sont pas matures et que
l'enfant vit de véritables tempêtes
émotionnelle qu'il est incapable de
contrôler et donc ça ne sert à rien de
lui parler d'une manière rationnelle
c'est l'accueil des émotions qui va lui
permettre de s'apaiser et cette écoute
empathique est aussi une des clés
fondamentales pour le développement de
l'estimé de soi de l'enfant elle lui
apporte une sécurité intérieure elle lui
permet de ressentir qu'il a le droit
d'être qui il est une autre clé très
importante c'est le fait de savoir
exprimer notre contrariété et de poser
des limites
en parlant de nous et en faisant des
demandes si je suis une enseignante qui
va rendre un contrôle aux élèves
si vous êtes l'élève et que je vous dis
5 sur 20 à ton devoir tune encore pas
travailler il serait temps d'y mettre un
peu sérieusement je me demande bien ce
qu'on va faire de toi
regardez ce que ça fait à l'intérieur et
si je vous dis plutôt tu as eu 5 à ton
contrôle et quand je pense à tes
résultats aux contrôles précédents
je suis inquiète parce que j'ai vraiment
envie de permettre à chacun de mes
élèves de réussir
et là je voudrais comprendre ce qui se
passe pour toi est-ce que tu serais
d'accord qu'on prenne un moment après le
court pour en parler ensemble
j'ai pas si vous sentez la différence
alors y'en a qui vont me dire oui mais
on n'a pas qu'un seul élève dans la
classe on n'a pas que ça à faire et en
même temps chacune de nos paroles a un
impact d'un côté quand je dis ça à cet
élève il ya tous les élèves qu'ils
sentent que ça se contracte à
l'intérieur il ya quelque chose à
l'intérieur qui a envie de réagir et ça
sortira au premier moment et de l'autre
côté est quelque chose qui détend et
l'intention de l'adulte qui étaient là
tout à l'heure mais le percevait pas là
elle est entendue par sept élèves là et
par toute la classe et ils sentent
qu'ils peuvent faire confiance
à sept adultes bien gentil peut-être me
direz-vous encore et là aussi les
neurosciences nous montre que l'enfant
est empathique par nature et que je suis
on lui parle avec bienveillance les
zones de son cerveau qui permettent de
prendre en compte ce que l'autre vit
vont se développer
par contre s'il vit des situations de
stress répéter ces zones de son cerveau
qui lui permettent de reconnaître les
émotions des autres ne vont pas se
développer correctement et ça va être le
début du manque de respect des conflits
et ça risque de l'impact et toute sa vie
et la difficulté c'est que nos modes
d'éducation actuelles sont basées sur la
croyance que l'être humain ne sait pas
distinguer le bien et le mal
alors on va lui apprendre avec une
éducation plein de jugement c'est bien
c'est mal tu es gentil tu es méchant et
ainsi qu'un système de punition et de
récompenses et ça ça entraîne de la
comparaison de la compétition ça impacte
l'estiment de soi et puis ça apprend
aussi à soi se soumettre à l'autorité
soit ça suscite de la rébellion
du coup potentiellement de la violence
est en tout cas la reproduction de ce
système de domination du plus fort sur
le plus faible
un autre regard est possible et ça
change tout si on voit l'être humain
comme un être sensible qui aime avant
tout contribuer au bien-être des autres
alors on va les geeks et avec l' écoute
de ce que vit l'enfant l'expression de
ce que nous vivons nous en tant
qu'adulte et puis une gestion des
conflits qui va chercher à prendre en
compte les besoins de chacun et là se
développe naturellement la coopération
ça renforce estime de soi ça développe
la créativité la responsabilité et le
respect de chacun
quelle que soit sa place alors quel
monde voulons nous un monde où l'enfant
puis ils adulent qui devient va agir par
peur de l'autorité et des sanctions ou
un monde où l'enfant puis l'adulte qu'il
devient va agir à partir de la
conscience et de l' envie de contribuer
au bien-être en moi c'est très clair je
préfère la deuxième option et j'ai
choisi d'agir pour ce monde là en 2008
un jour je me suis dit mais quel dommage
tous ces dégâts qui sont faits dans les
premières années de la vie d'un enfant
et qui vont impacter toute sa vie durant
l'adulte qu'il devient et quel gâchis à
l'échelle de la société tout entière
quand on voit les conséquences que ça au
niveau de la santé physique et psychique
au niveau de la paix sociale et au
niveau aussi de l'épanouissement des
talents de chacun alors j'ai décidé de
faire de la prévention est de faire
connaître cette approche pour que toute
personne en charge l'éducation puisse
avoir un moyen concret de vivre ses
intentions éducative bienveillante
et aujourd'hui je coordonne une
association au niveau national qui
oeuvrent pour faire connaître la
communication non violente qu'elle soit
accessible à tous parents et aussi à
tous professionnels de l'éducation dès
sa formation initiale et la bonne
nouvelle fixa bouge la communication non
violente est maintenant connue et
reconnue au niveau de l'éducation
nationale elle est citée dans un guide
pour une justice colère qui a été
réalisé par le ministère de l'éducation
nationale
il y à des inspecteurs et des chefs
d'établissement qui commence à se former
et la communication non-violente
commencent à apparaître dans les
programmes de formation continue des
enseignants du premier et du second
degré en 2009 on avait juste quelques
demandes d'établissement et c'était
surtout pour qu'on intervienne auprès
des élèves dans des classes où il y
avait le feu aujourd'hui c'est environ
peinado demandes par semaine
d'établissements scolaires que nous
recevons et qui nous demande pour mettre
en place une sensibilisation pour
l'ensemble de leur équipe en 2011
j'ai un pull fier à aix en provence une
formation qui s'appelle la communication
non violente au service de l'éducation
et aujourd'hui cette formation existe
dans cinq régions en france et bientôt
dans fait les participants à ces
formations sont des parents des
personnels qui travaillent en crèche des
animateurs des éducateurs et pour la
moitié ce sont des personnes qui
travaillent en milieu scolaire et elles
font une démarche volontaire de
formation elles viennent sur leurs
week-ends ou sur leurs vacances et elle
paye elle-même leur formation et je
tiens à le dire parce que même si vous
peut-être vous ne voyez pas encore ce
changement dans l'école de vos enfants
moi je peux vous dire que ce changement
pour une éducation bienveillante est en
route et qui s'étend
et qu'est ce que cela change
concrètement à l'école eh bien ces
enseignants accueillent les enfants le
matin en leur demandant comment ça va et
le prennent en compte
il instaure aussi des temps hebdomadaire
de régulation de la vie de la classe
quand il ya un conflit entre deux
enfants ils le gèrent avec la médiation
ils n'ont plus recours aux punitions et
du coup ils font aussi évoluer leur
pédagogie dans leur classe les enfants
ne restent plus toute la journée achi a
écouté ils peuvent bouger peuvent
prendre des initiatives
ils peuvent coopérer entre eux alors
comme vous le voyez j'ai le grand
bonheur de parti de contribuer tous les
jours un monde meilleur
j'ai la joie de voir les personnes
évolué et me partager ce que la
communication non-violente leur a
apporté comme par exemple un professeur
en collège qui me disait la
communication non violente a changé
complètement ma vision du métier en tant
que prof d'ailleurs j'allais le quitter
et j'y reste
elle m'a donné un outil pour communiquer
avec des êtres humains dont j'étais
totalement coupée ou bien une jeune
femme qui travaillait dans le
périscolaire pour la garderie avant et
après l'école et qui me disait avec
cette forme d' écoute mais quel bonheur
de voir un enfant qui passe de la colère
à la tristesse et puis qui finit avec un
sourire radieux et une enseignante en
primaire qui me disait eh bien
maintenant j'accueille les parents
totalement différemment je m'ouvre à
leurs difficultés
quand je ne me sens plus agresser quand
un parent arrive mécontents et du coup
je suis beaucoup moins agressive
alors vous aussi vous pouvez avoir la
joie d'être acteurs de ce changement
parce que nous nous sommes la génération
de transition nous avons appris à
travers ce que nous avons vécu une forme
de communication dont nous voyons bien
les effets dans la qualité de relation
que nous vivons pour le moment dans nos
familles au travail et dans notre
société tout entière
alors soyons le changement que nous
voulons voir dans le monde
parlons à nos enfants comme nous
aimerions qu'on nous parle
écoutons les comme nous aimerions être
écoutés gérons les conflits avec eux
comme nous aimerions qu'on gère les
conflits avec nous en nous informant en
apprenant ses formes de communication
bienveillante en les vivant avec nos
enfants nous avons un pouvoir énorme
nous avons le pouvoir en une génération
de changer le monde pour un monde plus
humain